Pourquoi s'embêter ?
Le jeu est truqué.
Mon vote ne comptera pas.
Les options sont horribles.
Voter, c'est pour les nazes.
Peut-être avez-vous pensé cela.
Peut-être avez-vous dit cela.
Si c'est le cas, vous n'êtes pas seul et vous n'avez pas totalement tort.
Le jeu de la politique publique est truqué de bien des façons.
Sinon, comment plus de la moitié des avantages fiscaux
reviennent-ils aux 5% des Américains les plus riches ?
Et nos options sont souvent horribles.
Pour nombre de gens venant de tous partis,
l'important est l'élection présidentielle de 2016.
Mais chaque année, vous pouvez regardez les scrutins
et voir des choses peu inspirantes.
Malgré tout cela, je crois toujours que voter est important.
Aussi fou que cela puisse paraître,
je crois que nous pouvons raviver la joie du vote.
Aujourd'hui, je veux parler de comment et pourquoi le faire.
A un moment de l'histoire américaine, voter était amusant,
se rendre aux urnes était plus qu'un triste devoir.
Ce temps de « la majorité de l'histoire américaine ».
(Rires)
De la révolution à l'ère des droits civils,
les États-Unis avaient une culture du vote
dynamique, fortement participative et mouvementée.
Il y avait du théâtre de rue, des débats en plein air,
de la nervosité et des fêtes,
des parades et des feux de camp.
Pendant le XIXe siècle, les immigrants et les machines urbaines politiques
ont alimenté cette culture du vote.
Cette culture a grandi avec chaque nouvelle vague de votants.
Pendant la reconstruction, les nouveaux votants afro-américains,
nouvellement citoyens,
ont commencé à exercer leur pouvoir,
cela a été célébré par des parades de joie
qui ont lié l'émancipation et leur nouveau droit de vote.
Quelques années après, les suffragettes
ont apporté un esprit de théâtralité à leur combat,
marchant ensemble dans leurs robes blanches
et réclamant le droit de vote.
Le mouvement des droits civils,
qui cherchait à faire honorer la promesse de citoyenneté égale
trahie par Jim Crow,
a donné un rôle central au vote.
Du Freedom Summer à la marche de Selma,
cette génération d'activistes savait l'importance du vote
et savait que la démonstration et l'exécution du pouvoir
sont la clé du réel pouvoir.
Mais cinquante ans ont passé depuis Selma et le Voting Rights Act
et, durant les années écoulées,
cette culture de vote face-à-face
a presque disparu.
Elle a été tuée par la télévision
et internet.
Le canapé a remplacé le quotidien.
Les écrans ont transformé les citoyens en spectateurs.
Il est sympa de partager des blagues politiques sur internet
mais c'est une citoyenneté assez silencieuse.
Le sociologue Sherry Turkle appelle cela « être seul ensemble ».
Aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
d'une culture électorale sur être ensemble ensemble,
en personne,
de façon bruyante et passionnée,
au lieu d'être comme « mange tes légumes » ou bien « fais ton devoir »,
voter puisse être plus comme « rejoins le club »
ou, mieux, « joins-toi à la fête ».
Imaginez si nous avions, à travers le pays,
des lieux locaux partout dans le pays,
des efforts conjugués pour raviver le face-à-face
dans l'engagement et les campagnes électorales :
des spectacles extérieurs où l'on se moque des candidats et de leurs causes
et on les glorifie de façon satirique ;
des discours donnés par les citoyens ;
des débats publics tenus dans des bars ;
des rues remplies d'art politique, de posters maison et de peintures ;
des concours musicaux où les artistes représentent leurs candidats.
Cela peut vous sembler dater du XVIIIe siècle
mais cela n'a pas à être plus vieux jeu
que, par exemple, « Hamilton » à Broadway,
qui est tellement contemporain.
Le fait est qu'à travers le monde,
aujourd'hui, des millions de gens votent ainsi.
En Inde, les élections sont colorées, ce sont des foires communales.
Au Brésil, le jour du vote est festif, dans le même esprit que le carnaval.
A Taïwan et Hong Kong, il y a un spectacle,
un spectacle attirant et impressionnant
dans la rue où le vote a lieu.
Vous pourriez demander si, en Amérique, nous avons le temps pour cela.
Je vous dirais
que l'Américain moyen passe 5 heures par jour devant la télévision.
Vous pourriez demander : « Qui a la motivation ? »
Je vous dirais
tout citoyen voulant être vu et entendu,
pas comme un accessoire ou un sujet de discussion
mais comme un participant, un créateur.
Comment mettons-nous cela en place ?
Simplement en le faisant.
C'est pourquoi avec des collègues
nous avons lancé un nouveau projet appelé « La joie du vote ».
Dans quatre villes des États-Unis --
Philadelphie, Miami,
Akron en Ohio et Wichita au Kansas --
nous avons réuni des artistes, des activistes,
des éducateurs, des politiques, des voisins, des citoyens moyens
pour créer des projets ensemble
qui peuvent encourager localement cette culture du vote.
A Miami, cela signifie des soirées avec des super DJ
où on ne peut entrer que si on est sur le registre des votants.
A Akron, cela signifie que des pièces politiques
sont jouées à l'arrière d'un pick-up
qui va de quartier en quartier.
A Philadelphie,
c'est une course au trésor thématique à travers l'ancienne ville coloniale.
Et à Wichita, ce sont des compilations et des graffitis en direct
au nord de la ville pour aller voter.
Il y a 20 projets
et ce qui est remarquablement beau est leur diversité
et ils changent les gens.
Je vais vous parler de quelques-uns.
A Miami, nous avons demandé à un artiste,
un jeune artiste du nom d'Atomico,
de créer des images colorées et dynamiques
pour une série d'autocollants « J'ai voté ».
Mais le fait est qu'Atomico n'a jamais voté.
Il n'était même pas inscrit.
En commençant la création de ses œuvres pour les autocollants,
il a réussi à dépasser son intimidation concernant la politique.
Il s'est fait inscrire,
puis il s'est renseigné sur les élections primaires à venir
et le jour de l'élection, il était dehors à donner des autocollants,
discutant avec les votants encourageant les gens à voter,
parlant des élections à des passants.
A Akron, la compagnie de théâtre appelée « Wandering Aesthetics »
a mis en place ces pièces jouées dans des camionnettes.
Pour faire cela, ils ont demandé au public
des discours, des monologues, des dialogues, des poèmes,
des extraits pouvant être lus à voix haute
et mis en scène.
Ils ont reçu des dizaines de propositions.
L'une d'entre elles était un poème
écrit par neuf étudiants d'anglais seconde langue,
des travailleurs émigrés hispaniques
vivant près de Hartville en Ohio.
Je veux vous lire ce poème.
Il s'appelle « La joie du vote ».
« J'aimerais voter pour la première fois
car les choses changent pour les Hispaniques.
Avant, j'avais peur des fantômes.
Maintenant, j'ai peur des gens.
Il y a plus de violence et de racisme.
Voter peut changer cela.
La frontière n'importe pas.
Ce n'est qu'un mur.
Le mur de la honte existe.
Il est très important de voter
afin de détruire ce mur de la honte.
Mon cœur est empli de passion.
Voter me procure une voix et du pouvoir.
Je peux m'exprimer et agir. »
Le projet « La joie du vote » ne concerne pas que la joie
mais aussi cette passion,
ce sentiment, cette conviction,
ce n'est pas que le travail de notre organisation.
Actuellement, partout à travers le pays,
des immigrants, des jeunes, des vétérans, des gens de toutes origines
se réunissent pour créer une activité passionnée et joyeuse
autour des élections,
dans les États de droite, de gauche, les villes, les campagnes,
des gens de toutes opinions politiques.
Ce qu'ils ont en commun est simplement ceci :
leur travail est lié au lieu.
Souvenez-vous, toute citoyenneté est locale.
Quand la politique devient juste une élection présidentielle,
nous crions et hurlons sur nos écrans puis nous effondrons, épuisés.
Mais quand la politique, c'est nous,
nos voisins et les autres personnes de notre communauté
nous réunissant pour créer des expériences de voix et d'imagination collectives,
alors nous nous souvenons que c'est important.
Nous nous souvenons qu'il est question d'auto-administration.
Ce qui me ramène là où j'ai commencé :
pourquoi s'embêter ?
Cette question a une réponse possible.
Voter est important car c'est un acte de croyance auto-réalisé.
Il nourrit l'idée d'intérêt mutuel qui fait prospérer une société.
Quand nous votons, même par colère,
nous participons à un acte de foi collectif et créatif.
Voter nous aide à générer le pouvoir que nous souhaiterions avoir.
Ce n'est pas par hasard que la politique et le théâtre
aient émergé à Athènes durant la même période.
Les deux sortent les individus de leur enceinte privée.
Les deux créent de superbes expériences publiques de rituels partagés.
Les deux donnent vie à l'imagination
et nous rappellent que, finalement, toutes nos obligations
sont imaginées et peuvent être ré-imaginées.
Ce moment
où nous réfléchissons au sens de l'imagination
est très important
et notre capacité à prendre cet esprit,
ce sens qu'il y a quelque chose qui nous dépasse,
n'est pas qu'une question d'expertise technique.
Il n'est pas juste question d'avoir le temps et la connaissance.
C'est une question d'esprit.
Je vais donner une réponse à : « Pourquoi s'embêter ? »
qui sera un peu moins spirituelle et un peu plus spécifique.
Pourquoi s'embêter à voter ?
Car il est impossible de ne pas voter.
Ne pas voter, c'est voter
pour tout ce que vous pourriez haïr et combattre.
Ne pas voter peut se déguiser
en un acte de résistance passive
mais, en fait, ne pas voter,
c'est activement passer le pouvoir
à ceux dont les intérêts sont opposés aux vôtres
et ceux qui seraient heureux de tirer avantage de votre absence.
Ne pas voter est pour les nazes.
Imaginez où ce pays en serait
si tous ceux qui, en 2010, ont créé le Tea Party
avaient décidé que la politique, c'était trop confus,
voter c'est trop compliqué.
Il n'est pas possible que nos votes créent quelque chose.
Ils n'étaient pas silencieux au préalable.
Ils se sont montrés
et, en faisant cela, ont changé la politique américaine.
Imaginez si tous ceux qui suivent Donald Trump et Bernie Sanders
avaient décidé de ne pas renverser le statu quo politique
et d'anéantir le cadre de ce qui était auparavant possible
en politique américaine.
Ils l'ont fait en votant.
Nous vivons actuellement à une époque
divisée, souvent très sombre,
où, à droite et à gauche, on parle beaucoup de révolution,
du besoin d'une révolution pour rompre la démocratie quotidienne.
Mais le fait est
que la politique quotidienne nous offre une stratégie de révolution.
Aux élections présidentielles de 2012,
les votants jeunes, latinos,
asio-américains, ayant de faibles revenus,
ont été moins de 50% à voter.
Aux élections de mi-mandat de 2014, la participation était de 36%,
la plus faible en 70 ans.
En moyenne aux élections locales,
la participation est d'environ 20%.
Je vous invite à imaginer 100%.
Imaginez 100%.
Mobilisez 100%
et, du jour au lendemain, c'est la révolution.
Soudain, les priorités politiques de ce pays changent considérablement
et tous les niveaux du gouvernement sont radicalement plus réceptifs
à toute la population.
Que faudrait-il pour mobiliser 100% ?
Il faudrait repousser les efforts amorcés
à travers tout le pays
pour rendre le vote plus difficile.
Mais, en même temps,
nous devons activement créer une culture du vote positive
dont les gens veulent faire partie
et qu'ils veulent expérimenter ensemble.
Nous devons créer un objectif.
Nous devons créer de la joie.
Oui, lançons une révolution,
une révolution d'esprit, d'idées,
de politique et de participation,
une révolution contre le cynisme,
une révolution contre la sensation d'impuissance auto-réalisée.
Votons pour donner vie à cette révolution
et, tant qu'à y être,
amusons-nous.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)